okay i think i'm live
i think i'm live uh
i restarted the computer and it fixed
nothing
the key the keyboard is just i don't
know what's wrong i i i hit all the keys
try to make sure that nothing's stuck
there might be a literal crumb stuck
under a key
you might want to just try flipping the
keyboard over and just shaking it
a bit that's what i'm
did i doing anything
[Music]
let's go i can play chess now
yes okay oh i feel played among us
i have not i feel i feel revived
let's go okay let me close our stream so
i'm not sniping
i close all the things
um okay let's do this
i have to remember my dragon theory or
my not my dragon what is this opening
spanish
this is spanish a spanish theory
okay so i i still have the blue arrow
d3 i know there's some
variation where i can still try a
marshall
is it here
let's play d6 okay
okay let's do this
which i even played here i guess i'll
play knight a5 and c5
um in queen c7 rook e8
i don't know any theory here
but hopefully it's okay
play g6
okay
so i want to go for this maneuver
and he's playing quicker this time
so i unnecessarily switched out the
mouse
i'm not entirely used to this mouse is a
little bit faster
but that's okay it's not too different
i'll play this move expecting that yeah
i think i'll preserve the bishop and go
for 96.
[Music]
96 some eventual b4 ideas
i mean white has potential to attack
maybe
f4 this is reminding me of the first
game i was black
the attack was very vicious but f4
shouldn't scare me i can take twice okay
c4 is interesting here
i'm trying to justify my knight also
trying to destabilize the structure
um what is this
that's actually oh that's an interesting
move
let's just pretend it's not scary
yeah i'm not it's too too scary to take
that knight
the pawn and g-file opening
i feel like i've played into my
opponent's comfort zone it's getting
messy
considering i make it even more messy
let's do it so much tension
let's take this
i just realized okay yeah i need to
anytime i click like a button
it prompts it down it like downloads
html file what does this move
do i dare take i mean this bishop is my
main defender
i don't think i want to take it i'll go
for this
now this bishop is strong
and the bishop's been working out
let's retreat going for maybe queen here
and
eventually mating
some before positional idea but time is
very good this game
[Music]
[Music]
be safe and be aggressive
i could probably i should call my
opponent's bluff and take the knight
or just take a pawn
okay so i'm scared i'm scared to click
the rematch
oh it works okay good beautiful
uh i'll play d4 again i'll stick with my
main repertoire
so that was the first three minute game
okay i think i i assume we're gonna play
all the games um
in the match no matter what so i just
want to keep being solid keep some
sanity
um play this move it's interesting idea
hmm
i like this position because
black's committed to h6g5 so it's likely
the king won't want to castle on the
king's side
i'll probably be stuck in the center
um
i could take with a rook
e5 is also interesting here i'll just
play e5
because takes takes there's a pin
[Music]
i can take on c7 yeah and then
rookie one also bishop d6 i give casting
bishop d6 wins exchange
okay this is this is nice
i got i won a pawn and i have the
compensation
[Music]
i really don't know what black does here
yeah okay let's um let's go for this
take this pawn and idea bishop c4
i have queen d8 i could also
like taking on h6 looks kind of
appealing
i'll start with this
i i i see the top of the chat so what is
this move
the favorite color question
wait what's material oh black has two
bishops for a queen
so that's good for me play g3
do you enjoy going to the casino or
what's your favorite card game
oh poker or choker
i i used to um the first time i ever
[Music]
played what's the best way to phrase
this
uh first yeah first casino experience
was vegas
it was national open 20
2014 2015.
and uh
wait okay let me let me focus um
i've i played poker for the first time i
i'd play the chess term i did terribly
in the chest room and then i played
poker and i won back like all my
all my travel expenses so it was nice
i went through a poker phase for several
months but
i haven't played too much recently
i don't play any other like casino game
i don't like to gamble
but i like games where like you have
some control over
um over your destiny
okay
nice position so my opponent's a fighter
it's good to know like he's lost
material but it's not resigning
oh green wins the pole
dad really i really
don't know what the issue is it might
just be the keyboard
but no time to worry
do okay and this
as long as the mouse keeps working
okay the king is safe and sound
uh yeah this is a threat and i'll win
the bishop
okay rematch let's go
okay no mercy
i think now's the time for stafford
yeah stafford time let's go let's get in
the rhythm
he might he might be prepared if he did
any preparation
the f3 is a a sign of preparation
um this is still interesting though is
f5
f4 is one of the ideas
there's a weird line now g4 queen h4
queen f2 knight g3
rook g1 bishop f2 or bishop um
bishop c5 and if takes i take and i win
the queen
i don't know if that's objectively good
but it's interesting
keep it up please say hello to me even
though i don't have the channel points
it's okay hello to finney finney i think
finney finney was like the
original inspiration of the hello
redemption
because finney finney would say hello
and no one would would respond
so everyone say hello to finney finney
thanks for subbing yet again
for five months
i like the fact it's leading to a nice
time advantage
there is some goal of breaking 2500.
uh it's logical i'm still probably much
worse here
but still fighting
right come on i want to do tactics maybe
bishop here
idea if um if g4 i have bishop h4
very sneaky i'm also just preparing
castling put more pressure on the file
and this is honestly a a line in the
stafford i don't really have
so much experience in but
it looks fun move the king over
hopefully those are not my my last words
bishop g4 is kind of insane bishop g4
takes takes
probably probably too dubious
you play b5 i'll play b5 why not
tempo move gaining space
just trying to apply pressure play b4
now i have some square for the bishop
i'm not sure where the bishop wants to
to settle
okay idea of taking and unleashing the
rook
it's weird like white has a nice center
but the pieces
and pieces lack harmony
bishop c4 is a good move
hmm
i'm debating whether to go insane i
think yeah let's go slightly insane
sake attacking another pawn i'm
expecting d5 and i'll play c6
i just want to open i want to like poke
holes in the center
make my opponent think some more
oh i kind of forgot that was
possible
player b6 idea of g6 again g4 i still
have this bishop h4 idea
wow let's keep attacking wow so many
pieces
directed at g3 it's so beautiful
white surviving though kind of where's
my win
the queen
where's my win oh f3 is kind of weak
let's play queen c8 idea bishop f1
i don't know white's on the flag though
it's a cool position
i actually don't know what's going on in
the final position
but that was a fun game the stafford
gambit success
hi eric you're my favorite do you want
to know how
to pronounce sergey zigor name
oh the zedh is pronounced like a jade
oh wait what treasure oh like
gigaco gigano
opponent's playing this can be a tricky
move order
do i say it right i feel like i've
always been criticized for
for mispronouncing his name
okay we have we actually have a mainline
london
it's interesting because my opponent i
think sometimes plays the london himself
so probably knows like a bunch of
different lines to play
so this is actually one of my favorite
main lines in the london
there's a lot of traps here
[Music]
um and yeah the whole idea of bishop b5
was to take
and basically set up this is one of the
traps
is uh now white is winning this pawn
there might be some way for boxing
compensation
i'll wind up with double c pawns
but yeah it's yet another
another reason to fear the london
let's trade queens
yeah there's definitely some i guess
sort of positional compensation
at the center
black has an extra like half open file
so i'm going to be going to try and be
solid
get the king involved always play off
three
oh there's some knight a5 idea
and knight a5 could be nice and just
kind of restrict the rooks
apply constant pressure to the pawn
also yeah basically preventing bishop c4
these pawns are menacing
black winds connect five man
of all these pawns it doesn't even feel
like i'm up upon but i am up upon
hmm but what to do
i can double up maybe it's hard to make
progress because my pawns are blockaded
i actually don't know what to do
at some point i want to open a file
maybe king
maybe i can take let's take king g1 and
i'll fight for that file
this could lead to trading all the rooks
be careful
okay now i don't have rook f1
hmm
what do i do here
this bishop is actually really strong
i have knight b3 but i don't see what
that accomplishes
okay i have an idea i'm going to play am
i scared of g3
[Music]
g3 is actually kind of scary
but let's start with this in g3 i play
rook f4 rook d2
black's going for the the end game
kingside attack
three maybe i'm probably not working
though
oh
i might want to play f4 actually
or no uh or a4 i mean
i have to play a4 at the right time
[Music]
let's go for this this looks interesting
down my knight
yeah oh that was a really bad move
i had my time
[Music]
not my proudest game
ah really not my proudest game well
flame
wow i just didn't know what to do i got
i got clobbered
well played
man the opening went so well but i just
didn't know what to do in the end game
there goes my rating okay let's let's
repeat the stafford
let's actually play this line that's a
funny line
d4 interesting oh he's a scotch
player
have you heard of doctor doom defense
would have been useful there can i get
his weapons by the way
what uh
i haven't heard of it but it sounds
scary
thanks for the bits let's play this move
i think i studied this at some point
it looks nice
is one of these like tricky gambit lines
or at least attempted gambit lines
which i don't don't think really works
out for white
now the pieces develop nicely there's
always queen b3 this is probably the
main resource
but if takes i have rook b8
knight g5 i have no h6 or knight e5
f7 is always defended by pretty much
everything
oh yeah don't don't redeem the blindfold
uh that'd be
i wouldn't be able to really type if so
definitely please know
okay i really like this position this is
nice
um i'd like to punish the queen
but how maybe king maybe this move
yeah just getting off the diagonal and
unpinning the pawn because i want to
play f6
kick away the knight to one of these sad
squares
we might see h3 here
probably bishop h5
yeah i think time is probably the
biggest culprit for my opponent
[Music]
almost almost as big of a culprit as my
keyboard issues
the keyboard the keyboard's still
unplugged
okay always play f6 bam
yeah i don't know what it does here
maybe each
h3 is a try
i think i'll just move back because the
knight still doesn't have a good square
and g4 would be kind of self-destructive
and that always covers e6
[Music]
okay so i want a piece that's nice
just have to stay solid
i'm actually i'm contemplating this move
it's a fancy move let's do it opponent's
low on time
try and end and the suffering
oh okay i have this move
a funny position i want to play king ga
mate i'm threatening this
oh it doesn't quite work
i can play this oh look at this move
bishop g4
it's such a funny move oh but then
the pawn can take what
wait how do i make this work
ah i can play rook look at this move
rook b4 because
the queen was annoyingly controlling g8
and now i take and then king g8
is not made because the bishop can block
or the queen can block
but king j8 is kind of cool okay
rick b4 was cool
yeah like it it led to
i wanted to stack the rook because it
led to the bishop sack
okay rematch wait did we all wait
i can't do math six plus
we played 11 games
right
oh so we play 14 okay so once we hit 14
then we play 10 in one minute
okay
i'll probably bust out e4 in the bullets
but london's been working well so
might as well stay with this
i would just have to improve on the
previous game wow it's eg
positively fabulous mate oh thanks so
much eg
appreciate that
i'm gonna mix up the opening i'll play
bishop d3 this is more of a main line
and the main main line is b6 e4 etc
i think knight h5 there's some weird
lines
um which i should
oh yeah bishop e7 e5 knight h5 and then
there's a very very long theoretical
variation
um which i know it's supposed to be kind
of dangerous for black
okay knight g7 i don't i haven't really
seen before
90 tries the main move so i'm playing h4
to prepare a greek gift
oh opponent's tempting me
do i do it let's do it
king g6 coming king g6 where's my mate
oh
okay now i think it's mating every line
right f5 g6 very important move
same thing f6 g6
so a couple a couple nice attacking
games
it's nice to have
so the best try for black is queen h4
hoping i pre-move this
uh okay that was nice yeah otherwise
like it's just unstoppable mates
okay that was a nice game 16 moves that
was the shortest game
um goes to show the the danger
of some of these lines let's repeat the
stafford
whoa it's joking thanks joking gifting
subs
oh so f3 again i'll repeat the same line
yeah so we're repeating the one of the
previous games
interesting i'm not scared of this
because i have queen h4
i know uh f3 is one of like the engine's
top choices
but it leads to like these weird crazy
positions and c3 is probably a good move
i'll play bishop d6 and going for the
sack
yeah there's so many like kind of fun
interesting ideas
and it still might just be dubious or
objectively good for white but
for blitz it's really fun
yeah i'm not going to calculate too much
even though maybe i should
i should have an idea of what's going on
here there's a funny line king e2
queen e7 king here and then this is mate
oh
uh
[Music]
i wanna i wanna punish white somehow
with some moves
i guess i'll play this first
i'm looking for moves after king f2
like there is there's 94
94 takes takes
and then the king really has nowhere
safe to go
i'm threatening to castle with check the
most ironic move
protecting miking and attacking white's
king simultaneously
opponent might be considering this but
then queen h4
yeah so the point i'm preventing the
king from really escaping like the king
has no safe place
bishops control these squares
um g6 is probably decent
okay now i can castle
i see the point so the king wants to
move back and then
my queen is attacked
i probably still will castle here
always nice to castle with check
if king here i could maybe maybe go for
this move
if king here i double check
i have to calculate king here
takes takes bishop here here queen e4
king h3 queen here rook here
bishop f1 king here
i mean let's go for it
oh i forgot the the bishop defends the
queen too i
i assume that rook was tied down
oh no my attack
i forgot the bishop moves diagonally
there's still some hope like i'm still
threatening discoveries
that was really bad though
queen here i have to be as tricky as
possible threatening this and maybe this
or this the queen can't actually oh it
could defend the rook
but then still this now this is actually
tricky again
i'm only down a rook for a pawn
and these pieces are are kind of out of
play
i've wrote that fade here
considering like queen queen g4 queen h5
and rook f8 seems to do a nice job
because the queen covers e6 bishop
defends the rook
calarook's attack knight d2 expected
okay it's a topsy-turvy game
and these stafford gamut lines are fun
i'm gonna keep the rook pins oh white
has two rooks for the queen
uh let's not plunder
keep this bishop aimed at e2
take this thing
here we go oh it's meeting
that's mate next move
oh that's a cool game i got i got a
little bit reckless
so okay we play one more three minute
and then then we go into bullets
okay um
i'll play e4 i don't know what he plays
i think he plays e5
i'll play a ponziani
i like playing ponziano against like
newer players against beginners against
stronger players sometimes it's
kind of a risk okay d6 is very welcoming
so there's a trap here if it takes i
play d5
um i'll play bishop and bishop e3
so takes d5 knight moves and queen a4
wins the knight
black could take if i take back there's
knight b4
i'll take with knight
yeah the the bishop was maybe better on
e2
oh i'm just losing a pawn
i was careless should have put the
bishop on c2
let's stay focused final blitz game oh
if i win this game i might
i might get back to 2500. maybe
i'm just down
careless opening mistake down the pawn
so this pawn is a target
idea rook d1
black wants to play d5 at some point
i'm gonna keep the pace
and this tension is kind of annoying
i could place e4
c4 b3 trying to secure some control also
preventing b5
so there's some what we call positional
compensation
uh just solely just with the pawn
structure the fact that
the pawn is backwards and i have control
over d5
and i'm okay with trading like if we if
we trade off the knights of bishops or
rooks
um that'll have very good control over
d5
with queen
that's a good move
i'll play play knight h4
hmm i'm considering bishop
some crazy like bishop d3 it's probably
no good
okay let's attack the bishop i'm 94
coming
wow
maybe bishop h5
box playing this well
and my knight really it's kind of stuck
i can't access f5 this knight's so
strong
so i'll probably want to trade it off i
have to be aware of 92 ideas
wow g5
i mean g5
i mean maybe just knight f3
i don't think 92 is so harmful because i
take take knight g5 and attack the rook
yeah i think opponent missed this um
but yeah this is one of the drawbacks of
g5 that gives me some
some opportunity to attack on the king
side
now the bishop's not defended i'm gonna
come out of this
probably winning if queen takes i play
this and i win the rook
if it takes or takes i win the the
bishop
i turned that turns around really
quickly
control the file go in for the kill
eventually
okay maybe we take a break
so
i'm just trying to think how to accept
the next challenge because i wanted to
i don't want to run into the same issues
as earlier
but i guess we'll take a break i'm ready
to accept the challenge whenever
i just request that he sends the
challenge i'll accept it for my phone
okay bullet time let's go let's do this
um 10 games of 1-0
good luck so we'll end when we have 24
games total
um i'll probably mix up the openings
we'll have some fun
uh which maybe
maybe we'll start after this game
because i'm i'm probably gonna play
london here
[Music]
i could use an external app oh maybe
there's a chrome extension
oh spam shift oh i'll look at it
afterwards
okay this is a fun line we had this
earlier
f3 so earlier he played g5
which allowed h4
um yeah i'm going to defend the because
i want to play g5 eventually
and before i play knight here and then
to c1
that's a scary move
the thing is i just want a pawn oh
that's a really scary move
uh let's weather the storm maybe
wow i want to move
oh that's really scary let's play this
it's getting really weird and he's
playing quicker than me too
don't hurt me
so there's no queen b6 but there's queen
a5 oh but the knight's attacked
i can take queen a5 queen c4
i think it's okay have this move too
ah actually forgot about that
but i think i'm alive now thankfully
kind of
a little bit of time let's attack on the
king side
[Music]
what is going on here uh
i don't know what's going on
ah
no
oh wow okay i felt i felt a little bit
slow
but i got the job done okay oh this
again
ah um
i'll play into whatever he wants to play
into i guess
max lange type thing i actually don't
know the theory in this line
there's some crazy variations where
things happen
um bishop e7
and bishop i have no idea what to do
here let's play bishop
i could bomb cloud
okay i could move the queen back i was
more scared of like losing d4
i think now everything's okay or is it
it's an annoying move
bomb cloud kind of
i just want to save the king there we go
this pawn's annoying
uh now my time
i don't know what to do here
let's play 97
to try and exploit the the light squares
only save your kids oh no the rook
wasn't hanging
okay defending mates
f3 i take it it's hard for white to stop
meats
okay man crazy that was a scary game
i think he's kind of outplayed me both
games like kind of
we've been getting really crazy
positions
um i'll play let's try in that manson
i'm gonna play the same opening that he
kind of just played
magmanson oh no
okay so this is kind of scotch-like
i'll take that f3
by the way i've i should mention this
more but my opponent is also streaming
the match
people can use the rodrigo command uh
to to watch from his channel um
and i believe there's commentators there
there's a grand master and international
master doing commentary on this
which people should definitely check out
um i've just been kind of wrapped up in
trying to survive here
i'm down upon he's outplaying me like
every game
but i'm oh i'm down on time too
the last few games i've been good on
time
i'm losing another pawn
i should see one da
the rook is almost stuck but d3 wow
okay i can't give up hope
what is this pawn structure
we both have menacing pawns ooh that's a
fork oh
you can take a check okay
defending
[Music]
take
attacking
down my queen no
ah i got made it ah good game well
played
okay let's focus let's focus i'll play
stafford again oh
he wants to play this oh tricky
um so he's tricking me into
whatever this is do we have this we have
this in earlier game
where i delete knight f6 i can take and
play this move
um just develop
this is pleasant
i think
okay i have to really watch time
and some queen g3 and i hear idea when
she stops
[Music]
let's move back f4 is a good move
i want to go for mating ideas like
knight h5
yeah okay so if i if i lose a night i
fork i triple fork
my knight is trapped my knight's trapped
i'm threading this good move
just have to survive i'm up on time damn
my bishop
okay it's gonna be dirty it's gonna be
real dirty
small children close your eyes
[Music]
okay i hope no small children were
watching there
it was really dirty okay purell
sanitize let's move on
okay um let's go back to london let's
um oh it's uh
this is called a horowitz defense maybe
soon to be hippo
what is this h5 coming
oh it thinks gabador lies
oh keep reminding me it'll it'll happen
it'll happen sooner the more you keep
reminding me
okay i want to play f3
interesting oh the square is available
this pawn's weak now the pawn's now
defended
i'll keep attacking the pawn
idea 92
take this
play g4 oh g4 hangs upon
okay this pawn is also attacked going
for f4 maybe
defend the pawn
yeah at this point i'm just going for a
queen side attack
knight c6 coming
yeah it's it's a party with a la queen
pawn and black's king
okay that was nice nice little mating
pattern
rematch
okay i'll play oh this again
what do i do against this
i like knight f6 maybe tachopong
oh this is like a petrov kind of
the white kind of gambiting
looks fine though i have a nice uh oh
that's a good move
let's take and play this yeah
nice pawn structure uh let's keep
trading
i'm gonna try and play a clean game for
once
trade
oh and not get mated maybe we can
oh oh f7 is a target too
how do i defend everything
can i defend it oh i can take the rook
first
yeah oh it's still scary though
play this move
i've wasted a lot of time there but
if i if i didn't play the right move i
would lose
okay
still alive
interesting
we're gonna trade down everything i
think i'll be up a pawn in the end
though there's queen
queen b7 but i can take
now my rook is still pinned
unfortunately
okay so i'm up upon
okay i wasn't scared of stalemate might
have too many pawns
okay four more games let's go
i'm trying to think what to play like
what can i play to be tricky
what is we played the weird
like hippo stuff that actually works
well
oh it's an england gambit england
time kind of
yeah i don't mind this i guess i lost
back the pawn
okay so we just have kind of a balanced
position
and we both have double pawns bishop
versus knight
the box probably a little bit better the
knight is more effective than the bishop
the rook somewhere
[Music]
going after the knights a5 is a good
move
i think i'll just sack it's interesting
i have to sneeze
ah i can't sneeze i don't know why
there there in this move
this is scary
okay positional chess
more positional chess
hmm
if i need to take maybe
so i have a lot of pawns i want to keep
the rook on the board
oh it's a time scramble f5
yes it's a fork
okay
let's go three more games
what to play i'll play
one of these colorado time
an attempted colorado gambit
uh i can take maybe
this is either really good or really bad
oh
it's probably really good
um let's go for this
now this is getting interesting g3
g3 probably h5
h4
this bishop is such a hero
oh am i in trouble
i might be in trouble
uh-oh
uh oh
wait
this is really bad um
where is my survival chances
do this move
i have eight seconds left
ah
oh there we go okay some hope again
i was close i pre-moved like the last 20
30 moves man ah
good game good game
okay let's play bishop c4 and queen e2
cool line
play rook that's a good move
um give away the bishop hair
my heart rates went up that uh that last
game
to calm down calm down
um play knight c3 95
offering the queen trade it's so
tempting to take the knights but
i'll resist
okay
we can trade
so black is a bishop here but the pawns
are kind of locked
not sure what my plan is f6 is a good
move
oh that's a good move too
my time
i'm sacking pawns for i guess positional
reasons
i'm getting outplayed go for this move
here goes all my pawns
no yes
oh wow i won dirty flag oh he played
really well
i feel kind of bad but one more game
one more game let's go um
this d4 moves coming i can play a scandy
i'll play scandi
i'll try and get like icelandic or
portuguese
oh what's icelandic like e6 i think this
is icelandic actually
bishop b4 and castling
so i'm trying to gambit opponents not
behaving though
okay so i have the of this file
we actually have kind of a normal
position play this move
and take and take queen e7
bishop f6 maybe i take with pawn even
because i just want to keep the pressure
that's a good move i forgot about rook
a2
play this and bishop b7
okay so i have a time advantage that's
nice i have a nice fiend caddo
oh there goes my fiance
it's still pleasant also up upon
um long rookie two or rookie one
oh free knight okay
that was a nice break okay
i got through the match
the the games were definitely closer
than the score indicates
i was losing a lot of the bullet games
um i had some interesting fights that
was fun
uh shout out again i wish i how do i
pronounce this
this name amboa so vitika
um people should check them out link is
in the chat
i think i'll try and join the um
the call again give me one moment
okay i'm joining
hello eric hey how's it going hey man
how are you
right i'm doing well i'm not a north
american i
am the result of the match not with
simon
yeah now i i'm sorry for all these
technical issues the keyboard just
stopped
functioning but uh
had some uh some fun final games there
it was it was a lot um
yeah i think there were really
interesting positions you never
disappoint
so it was always very fun to see the
positions that we got into with you and
um
i know that rodrigo is um i'm sure he's
gonna be wanting to
study a little more and get the rematch
going in a couple of months maybe
um sure definitely yeah definitely some
some openings
to uh to review with a lot of these
london lines a few stafford gambits
we saw that the stafford and then the
funny thing is like they played the
london normally but i guess because you
know you're like
leading the world's leading expert in
the london he didn't want to play that
ah yeah no i i checked a few of his like
openings beforehand so i was expecting a
london
i had some interesting things prepared
but i'll have to keep them secret
but yeah thank you thank you again for
accepting the uh the challenge we uh
we went full uh full eric rosen mode
here you know
eating thai food drinking tea using
alexa
wow oh i'll have to watch it that that
sound that sounds like heaven
yeah it was like it was a fun time it
was a fun time and we really appreciate
everybody in your channel that came over
to follow um
and i know that someone that jika came
over and
and he gifted a few subs so we
appreciate that oh that's awesome
yeah it was really awesome it was really
awesome i i know like
chat was being very helpful with like
communication to like trying to
um there was a one moment i sent a
challenge and i don't think it went
through and then we were both kind of
stalling and then
yeah chad eventually caught
helping us comments as well oh very nice
i'll have to re-watch the commentary i
think
as the match went on there were there
were more and more blunders from
uh from both of us but that was
expected it was expected but i mean any
overall impressions over the match
anything that uh
you would suggest for the future or
anything like that
um i enjoyed it i i
i really um i enjoy matches like this
where it's like uh
it's a nice mix of the blitz and bullets
and um
it's nice to kind of uh i guess play a
few dozen games against the same person
and try and scout out like their
weaknesses
um and in terms of suggestions for the
future
i don't know maybe that's a better
question for chats if uh
if they have if they have any feedback
or want to see a different format um
very good
fair enough for enough i think um so i
mean hopefully we'll be able to do this
again
in the not too distant future i sent you
a whisper um
you know just whenever you get a chance
to want to get me there oh sure yeah
thank you again thank you so much for
your time uh marcelo
rodrigo do you guys want to say anything
yeah no first of all congrats eric for
winning the match and again also thank
you
i mean we really enjoyed the match we
enjoyed really interesting chess
of both of you guys actually i i really
just have
uh one question that uh one chess
question
sure is some curiosity on this staff for
gambit
uh you know i i know the i think the f3
is the the best move against this stat
for
so f3 is one of the computer's top
recommendations i was talking about this
on stream it's one of like the best
moves according to the engine but it's
tricky to play
because of this knight h5 f5 idea
so okay yeah there there's a different
line
involving d3 and bishop e2 and c3 which
i think is
if you just know a few moves it it kind
of kills the whole opening all right
well i i actually i don't know if you
remember but i have a game with you in
the stafford that was really interesting
f3 and c3 and i luckily was able to win
that game but you had me like
very you were mating me even to the end
oh wow
i'll have to dig it up yeah um yeah it
requires like doing very awkward stuff
where you just like push pawns like f3
c3 d3 and trying to be solid
my king went to like
[Music]
right yeah it's one of these openings
like if you know what to do against
then i'll probably like stop playing but
and the games we had were actually it
was it was fun
right now for me and especially for
bullet i mean
should work very well right the staff oh
definitely yeah i mean if the if the
opponent doesn't know it
um but if they know it and they're
prepared then it's uh
it's not the best opening choice yeah
they have to change it
really tricky say it again
it was really tricky right yeah like
even if you know f3 and you know like a
few ideas like sometimes you you have to
to know it deeper um yeah i
i i was i was fully expecting to see
like a halloween game
i forgot about the halloween i was
trying to get a nakmansen towards the
end
but we didn't go into the line i really
loved one
checkmate you you made uh made
um the ruby rock before yeah
[Music]
i was disappointed that king g8 wasn't
mate because it's not too often you move
your king with checkmates
but yeah okay yeah yeah
there's a there's a game i don't
remember now who commented it if it was
feingold or if it was uh
if it was yasser and i think it was one
of those where it was either rook or you
could long cast when it was checkmate
and they asked him
why uh he played the rook as opposed to
the long castles and the
guy was like well you know i'm an
engineer so i look for whatever's going
to be the easiest and it requires this
effort to move the route
yeah i know what you're talking about i
think it was like some lasker game this
uh this famous queen
yeah it was crazy thank you eric thank
you guys for uh for the
i appreciate it yeah more and more
people are doing that these days so
congratulations thanks so much yeah yeah
i will try and make sure that
uh the people like every everyone in my
chat can can check you guys out on
twitch and youtube
so thank you thank you very much
sounds good well have a good night take
care